(airplane taking off)
- For those who can't afford to travel,
what is the best way to expand your mind?
- That's a great question, Katie.
I think the reality would be if you live
in a cosmopolitan city
like Toronto, New York,
or near a city, you could actually go
and there's tons of amazing communities,
you know, there's massive
Cantonese communities,
Mandarin community,
Indian community uhm...
Bangladesh community and all these places.
So, again, it depends.
First of all, kind of
stick to what is your idea?
What is your product?
What is your mission?
And then think about where is the audience
that's going to be the
market for your product?
Who are going to be your customers?
And then, even, physically you might find
that there's cities near you
where they're well-represented
or the demographics are well represented.
And then the next question,
if that's not the case,
I don't know, say you you live
in the middle of the Midwest in the U.S.,
in a kind of rural community,
then the great news is
the power of the internet
has changed everything
in the last 20 years.
So, you an go online,
you can find anything
because you got an encyclopedia
at the palm of your hand,
where you can find, and,
the other thing I have found
some great entrepreneurs recently.
They've just build a virtual business,
of colleagues that met around the world
through the internet.
You know, there's actually
someone who's published a book,
and they self-published it,
and they actually got the
editor, I think, from Turkey.
You know, they're out of New York state,
but they got the guys,
in terms of the
book-binding, out of Canada.
So, you know, the world is a virtual world
that's all there for you.
And I think the opportunity,
and actually this really helps
diversity and creativity,
is there's tons of resources
and brilliant people around the world.
What, there's seven billion people,
but there's a lot of people
who want to support your success,
or your idea, who are untapped resources.
And they can either, even be mentors
to you to help you on your journey
and through social media,
there's a great way of
connecting with them also.
And the nice thing about,
you know, social media is
there's almost a bond of trust.
It's almost like, when we meet people,
we have to get to know them,
but with social media,
you kind of meet someone
socially (laughs),
and you automatically trust them.
And if they have got something
that helps your idea come to market,
then why not, it's worth
testing that and pursuing that.
And you actually can build a business
and you can educate yourself, Katie,
I think, very clearly around
where is your audience?
Where is your market?
And who is the network
of people I need to do
to make that idea come to
reality and build a business?
And it's all available through social,
and it's all available
through the internet,
So, we're really encouraged
and obviously are really (mumbles)
about coming on this show.
There's probably loads of
people who are listening now,
talking, paying questions and
who could be really powerful
in your network to help
your idea come to market.
- Listen, Katie, I think this
is part of entrepreneurship.
You never have all the resources you want
to do the thing that you want to do.
You've got to find another
way to get started, right.
Don't let the fact that you
don't have the money to travel
be the reason why you don't go out
and try to expand your mind, right?
And I don't have a building,
so I can't, you know?
We're always going to have these reasons
why we can't do the things.
Entrepreneurship's about
resourcefulness and finding a way.
So what can you do in your
local city to find a way?
Maybe there's meet-up groups, you know?
There's salsa classes here in Toronto.
I don't have to go to a different country
to learn how to dance salsa.
There's different activities
you can do around.
There's different videos you can watch.
I learn a ton from my own videos,
where we cover,
you guys give us suggestions
on videos, people to cover.
People I've never heard of,
who have had massive success
in countries outside of North America.
I get to learn from that.
And so, it's just finding a way.
What do you want to learn?
What are the skills?
What are the people you want
to be able to connect with?
There's probably a local group
already covering that in some way,
and if not, there's definitely one online
that you can get involved with.
So, much more, just
about the resourcefulness
than the lack of resources.
(plane taking off)